a
palette really this is not new we just
got a we just got a look at it all right
look at it look at all you want that's 3
days old that's not 3 days old yes it is
that one probably 3 days old but that
one's FR no it's not ma'am it's it's
literally oozing still no it's not cuz I
picked it what's her
name Emily Wilson Emily Emily are you do
you feel like you're okay yeah I I'm
100% okay so are you refusing medical
attention from these no I want like if
they feel like I need it that's fine but
is not fresh okay if you say it's not
fresh it's not fresh that up here
all what up here light up where what up
it's does anything hurt are you injured
no okay that's fine we just want to know
we just make sure you're okay if you're
saying you're okay then you're okay all
we just want to make sure you're okay
right now our main do not
project anything I have nothing in my
car look no one's projecting anything we
just want to make sure came out of
nowhere
face can
you yeah um just turn my front ones
off
actually just back yeah just back this
car up a little bit cuz I'm going to do
the test on this on this line right here
cuz this will be perfect right
there I haven't manipulated anything and
I also have video okay um so are you
refusing their medical attention that's
fine if you are that's fine if you
saying you're okay then you're okay I'm
fine okay that's fine then you're you're
going to refuse their medical attention
then right yes I just want but when it
comes to the police we just got to make
sure you're okay that's all I'm fine so
you don't need any medical attention no
I'm good okay all right okay you have
you have but but I need you to stay
around because I do not trust them okay
all right can you uh come with me over
here this way so you uh just to make
sure you're refusing medical attention
right no I just don't trust we who us or
them who them either of you I don't know
what's what's your name I'm Emily Emily
what
Wilson all right Emily Wilson why are
you going to
call Emily Emily look look I'm talking
to you no that's crazy Emily look at me
no I have family that okay listen in the
forest I cannot listen to me
Emily 1123 1999 Cherokee I don't
know are you
injured you're fine you're saying tell
okay 100% good all
right all right so sounds like she's
refusing medical attention to me we
refusing medical attention nothing
happened you
guys you just got into an accident we
just want to make sure you're okay you
say you're not injured then you're not
injured fine I just want to go home well
we well we have to do our part two so I
just want to make sure you're not
injured I'm done okay you're not injured
okay that's okay that's all right you
say you're not injured and no one got
hurt then it's just a car that's fine I
don't need to charge all right so we're
just going to step back here I cannot
afford a charge so we're just going to
step back here and I'm going to come
talk to you okay all right talk to me
hold on hold hold on relax all your
money relax relax relax relax come here
you're fine Emily come over here don't
go over there come over here come to me
high speed chases T we got to unruly
suspects I will kill that mother T me no
do it stay in the blue box I like it Kik
dramatic DUI I'mma pass everything that
she trying to do and shocking body cam
footage hey get the go get on the ground
law and crime presents body cam the
place for real raw and wild police
videos you should have seen it it was
good it's on body camera I'll show it to
you catch the action and subscribe to
our new YouTube channel
now you want make sure you're okay I am
not okay what's
wrong are you just upset no I'm going
through a separation right now okay so
you're upset right now this is my first
time out in 10 years okay I don't know
how to act I'm sorry all right don't
don't go over there come over here no I
can't I'm just relax relax look just
relax relax
all right I'm just going to use sign
over
here okay what do you want me to do on
sit on this line right here you me do
this stand right here see where I am
stand right there all right you're going
to put your feet together just like that
your hands to your side just just how
I'm doing it I'm just going to do a
couple tests all right okay I'm super
drunk I'm sad I'm alone well we're going
to work through that okay do you have
any medical conditions with your eyes
I'm do you wear glasses cont 40% color
blind you're color blind okay
I'm
okay all right I'm sorry it's all right
it's okay okay just look at the the tip
of my pen okay don't look at the flash
just look at the top of the pen please
don't make me do this I I have to do
this test in order to Mo forward okay so
make me do this right now I already paid
$50,000 all right just look at the top
of the pen just follow with your eyes
and your eyes only okay just keep your
hands to your side for me
okay and just follow with your ice and
your ice only all right
mhm just follow the zp of the pen okay
okay you're doing good I'm just it's all
right you're doing a good
job really
sad I'm really alone well right now
you're not alone we're all here it's all
right okay just just keep looking at the
tip of the pen and just follow right
with your eyes and your eyes only
okay
what
contact you're wearing contact right now
yes okay so they Bubble Up
okay just just follow the top of the pen
just with your eyes Okay do you
understand
sir
I'm like not very drunk I'm just really
sad it's all right
okay just just follow the top of the pen
all
right
my eyelashes your eyelashes again the
way okay all the contacts the eyelashes
I really don't all right we're almost
done with this
test just
PR
we're going to do a couple more tests
all right I'm going to show you how to
do them and just going to wait for my
instructions to be done and then you can
start in the middle of the road that's
all right we're blocking it no one's no
one's Sur it's just us it's okay all
right so I'm I'm going need to stand in
front of this line right here facing
this way you're going to face that way
you want to tie your shoe so you don't
fall no do you want me to walk
yep that's fucking crazy
bro all right good job all right so I'm
going to tell me good job I'm not a
fucking T all right so you're going to
keep your feet together no hold on hold
on hold on don't start yet tell how you
start you're going to keep your feet
together just like I'm doing it right
just uh just watch me real quick so I
can show you the stting position just
look at me Emily you're going to place
your right foot in in front of your left
foot with your heel touching your toe
with your hands to your side okay that's
going to be the starting position go
ahead and try to do that okay well wait
let me put
my I don't even think I can do it okay
all right you want to try to do a
different one then all right let's try
do a different one no I just want you
guys to give me a break and bring me all
right so you want to try doing that test
or you want to tr okay no all right no I
just want to go home we're going to try
to do another one all right okay wait
it's okay we'll try to do another one
hold on I'm not hold bro it's all right
it's okay please let me go home so you
going to stand right there on the line
again no I just want to go home hav
stand by for a second actually don't
want to go home at all so bring me to
jail all actually it's okay just relax
relax relax how can I relax we're just
trying to do this I just got to do my
job real quick I got do one more test
and that's it okay so just s what the
fuck is that don't you dare tote my car
we have to we have to pull your truck
out hold on hold on stay over here stay
over here don't you dare tote my car
stay over here to it's broken down no
it's not Emily Emily let me finish the
test real quick okay what the fuck I'm
talking to you don't don't worry about
him right now my
car let me talk to you for a second
let's keep doing this test my sister
works for a towing company and my
brother is a police officer so what the
fuck I don't know who your brother is
I'm sorry I don't care I'm not trying to
use that so you're going to keep your
feet together and you're going to race
either your left or your right
foot right in front of you approximately
6 feet 6 in off the ground please just
bring me home I have to do we have to do
all this test first before we do
anything else all
right I am hammered I
okay do you think you can do this test
or not it's okay if you can't might to
pass it I don't know no okay all right
so we're we're just going to stop right
now go ahead put your hands behind your
back arrest me no un
arrest please don't arrest me relax
don't put your hands behind your back no
not yet just relax don't your hand we're
going to we're going to let you call
somebody just don't pull away okay pull
away just relax
relax
got oh my God you're really getting me
no no relax relax relax all right just
stand up stand don't don't don't throw
yourself on the ground I'm not lock
it
really what the man you lock
it not yet not yet not yet we'll grab
your stuff from
you're going to ruin my life right now
you know that I should put in the back
of your car for now you're going to ruin
my life do you know that do you know
that you have a double double or
one oh my
God please don't fucking do this don't
pull away don't pull away no you're not
going to do this to me right
now sweat your
head put your other foot in there you're
really yes put put on the please just
bring me home I didn't do anything
put please put both of your feet in
there don't don't put your foot in there
you just going to please just bring me
home instead we're going to grab your
your uh
purse fucking make money off me okay
Emily just sit he going to try to put
your seat belt on please bring me home
I'm just going to try to put your seat
belt on okay please just bring me home
you just turn your head to the right for
me really Emily really Emily put your
back in what did I do don't worry about
it we're going right down the road
anyways sounds
good okay we want to thank Morgan and
Morgan for sponsoring this body cam
video I mean I think it's pretty clear
from the body cams that we cover that
it's not always safe out there when
you're hurt it can be confusing it can
be scary you don't really know where to
turn well Morgan and Morgan is actually
the largest injury law firm in America
and in a time when you already have so
much to think about they're going to
make it super easy for you they have
completely modernized the process
because you submit your claim you sign
contracts you upload documents you talk
to your whole legal Team all on your
phone that's it an attorney is going to
review your case in just eight clicks
also they have 4,000 support staff that
can help you too which is just amazing
to think about and in terms of price
well you only pay them if you win
there's no upfront fee so if you're
injured and you want to join the over 3
million people that call them every year
you can submit a claim at www.
forthepeople.com
lcam or by dialing pound law that's
pound 529 on your
phone losing this shit up or I'm going
to press so many charges I am not
hostile I am not resisting arrest please
loosen up my
cuffs give me access to my belongings
that are
not give me
my
really you're going to impound my car I
just told you how poor I
am I know the chief of
police
please loosen up my let me get
my
phone
[Music]
please
crazy
can somebody please talk to
me
really
I fucking hate
everyone good fucking
thing
yeah somebody please loosen this
shit a little bit we're heading in right
now okay can you just loosen
it my L is all of you up so much I am so
much under the limit you
guys
you up too
motherfucker please just loosen this
up I have never been
out don't you dare go anywhere where are
you
going away from my car
what the bro that's crazy what did I do
wrong can you give uh the
um okay but what the
fuck you're not giving me any
information you're going back to station
okay
why process
you to process me for
what
driv I
wasn't you guys are all
bro in this town you're
just
really can't you just bring me home
my first day out as a single woman
you're going
to I don't even know how to act and
you're going to bring me in you're going
to charge me
really
you really what did I do you're going to
process me
no no I can't get out I have no one to
call shut the really you're to process
me
no no
please please don't please don't do this
to
me
really
really what did I do you could have just
brought me home
you could have just brought me home I
can't do that why I didn't do anything
wrong I went out I got
drunk okay he left
me you're going to do this to me right
now I got three kids really you going to
leave me
you're going to make me pay for this
fuck you that's fucking crazy I didn't
do anything wrong you just should have
brought me
home oh my
God you should have brought me home you
should have brought me home I didn't do
anything wrong I can't do that I didn't
do anything wrong
I'm just
sad you're gonna charge
me
you what the
man I was out at that bar drinking by
myself with all these creeps coming up
to me all I want to do is watch
soccer you're a soccer fan so am
I soccer F what's your favorite team you
look a lot like that cute guy the other
guy nobody
cares it doesn't matter bro you can work
your ass
St
everyone 106 11
really
[Applause]
yeah I operated a vehicle a little bit
inebriated less than 5 miles away from
my
house I'm super
sad the the 450 forms I I can go grab
him
this stop braiding up
[Music]
forms fuck
what yeah you still have to do
one yep
yep yep
I'm not a bad person I do not drink and
drive no one bad person no I've already
done this the with the you pull me over
and then I get
$20,000 in findes can somebody please
brush the hair away from my face for a
second
yeah want no
like my eyes sorry all of it all of it
all of it please no all of
it no all of it your hair like
this
more I know you're just being
careful that somebody like like actually
brush my shit away from my
face
time I'm way more happy
being somebody like loosen up this shit
the
are they too tight did you uh super
tight and you're both like what like
waterm yeah can you please loosen this
shit up I'm Filipino I don't look it but
please somebody fix yeah he's going to
almost make a lookist for you okay
please I don't need extra charges we're
not trying to give you an extra charges
please don't give me any charges I can't
we just have to do our job
just really you hate them too wash my ha
all right just want to make sure that
you acknowledge and have an advice of
your constitutional right as initial off
on the form I want a lawyer you want a
lawyer okay that's
fine my purse though please not yet not
yet once we're done with everything can
I just have my B for a second a
cigarette
something right now a cigarette on
you this is crazy that I'm locked up
right now I didn't do anything wrong I
met a friend out for drinks I separated
from
my of a
pu
everyone oh leave him leave him go out
have fun really you're going to I have I
have to read this form before we do the
other test all right you've been
arrested for dry while
intoxicated njsa
39450 the law requires you to submit
samples of your breath for the purpose
of testing did to determin alcohol
content okay I did a record of the taken
of the breast samples including the test
results will be made upon your request a
copy of that record will be made
available to
you
after you have provided us samples of
your breath for testing you have the
right at your own expense to have a at
my own expense I have no expense I have
no extra money I fuck I'm on food stamps
to have a person or physician of your
own selection to take independent
samples of your breath blood or urine
for independent
testing if you refuse to provide samples
of your breath you will be issued a
separate summons for refuse for the
refusal a court may find you guilty of
of both refusal and driving while
intoxicated it wasn't if a court finds
you guilty of the refusal you will be
subject to various penalties including
license revocation of of up to 20 years
a fine of of up to
$2,000 installation of a ignition
interlock capitalize fucking and
referral to an intoxicated Drive
Resource
Center these penalties may be in
addition to penalties imposed by the
court for any other offense of which you
are found guilty you have no legal right
to have an attorney physician or Y what
the fuck I'm going to you have no legal
right to have an attorney physician or
anyone else present for the purpose of
taking the bread samples you have no
legal right to refuse to give or delay
given samples of your breath
I'll read the end
again you have no legal right to refuse
to give or delay giving samples of your
breath any response from you that is
ambiguous or conditional in any respect
to my request that you provide bre
samples will be treated as a result to
submit breath samp breath testing even
if you agree to take the test but then
do not follow my instructions do not
properly perform the test
or do not provide sufficient breath
samples I will charge you with refusal
to submit breath testing I repeat the
lord requires you to submit samples of
your breath for testing will you submit
the samples of your breath of of your
yeah off your breath yeah yes or no yeah
I I just need yes or no answer yes okay
thank
you
I'm not
Shar
breath